hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong if you're a
returning favorite then congrats you're
a member of our fresh ketchup crew if
you're new to the show welcome home my
name is mark ellis and i am the host
today i'll be steering the ship or
playing the game as it were for this
particular episode my wonderful co-host
jacqueline coley is off today because
she's on vacation she's probably having
her toes touch the sand of some exotic
hawaiian locale meanwhile i'm here in
los angeles and you know people tell me
mark you work hard you should take a
vacation sometimes but then i start to
think about it and i get to talk movies
and tell jokes for a living because of
everybody who's listening or watching
the show right now my entire life is a
vacation so thank you and we're going to
talk about a movie that has i guess some
sort of vacation destinations but it
would be a bold move it'd be a bold move
if you went to any of these places that
are depicted in the film because we're
talking about
jumanji the 1995 jumanji the og the one
that kicked it off starring robin
williams bonnie hunt couple of cute
tikes including gears to dunst so
that movie shockingly i know i'm going
to break a lot of inner children hearts
right now it's 52 percent rotten on the
tomato meter if you can believe it it is
barely fresh on the audience score was
62 but it's still i don't know sounds a
little low to me so we're going to be
talking about that with three very
special guests who happen to be dear
friends of mine who have launched a new
podcast endeavor underneath their banner
of the world girls that's right roxy
steph and dorine are going to be joining
me momentarily but first big fan shout
out time everybody seems to uh be
begging for us to talk about jumanji and
that's been going on for quite some time
here you go so you're welcome sean
mcgrahan jacob schrader nicholas
bayfield he's a returning champ solo
rado and english teacher alex hellyer
and his year eight students so everyone
in alex's class right now i want you to
pay attention spit the gum out bang
erasers after class and right now pay
attention to whatever professor
hellyer's telling you because he has
good taste in film or at least for this
one and i don't really have good taste
in anything except when it comes to
choosing guests for this show because
producing lucy and i were talking it
over we said who could we have to step
in for jacqueline and who could we have
as a special guest talking about jumanji
and then like a bolt the lightning had
hit us the stars of the new podcast
[ __ ] out of water i didn't come up with
the title i'm just the messenger here
underneath the world girls banner it is
steph sabra dorina ariano and roxy
streier my three pals welcome to the
show everyone good to have you all back
i want to get into the podcast y'all it
just started we're gonna do that after
we talked jumanji but first before i say
hello to roxy and dorina steph zabra you
are back from a whirlwind vacation that
literally took you to all parts of the
globe yeah i can't believe i'm back it
doesn't feel like it but i was texted
mark when i was away i was like guess
what work i am now drinking beer so now
our friendship can really excel to the
next level as we have a beer together
hopefully uh after this jumanji episode
that's right we are shifting into third
gear and we'll have the uber driver do
that because we're going to be drinking
some brewskis because steph is on board
dorina you and i have shared many a uh
an adult beverage you prefer the uh the
mezcal tequila i do mark but i do enjoy
the ipa as you know because we both like
very bitter things like our adult uh
very bitter uh souls but i think we're
bitter inside but towards the world
we're happy right every time i see you i
know you want to have this dark soul and
i believe that it's there and i do not
want to be cursed in any way but you are
a bright light in a cruel world as is
roxy streier roxy one of the greatest
backgrounds and a deserving one for you
because you are our hollywood star
yeah but it just says it says hollywood
i messed up i'm i'm here in hollywood
and that feels like my life here i am
the queen of hearts
yeah it's hollywood adjacent so
i'm thrilled to talk to you all about
jumanji because it seems like this was a
movie that a lot of people's childhood
centered around i mean we loved robin
williams as an actor as a comedian he
was great in aladdin but then jumanji
comes along and it just sort of felt
like oh man this is like a great kids
90s movies
52 rotten on the tomato meter i'm going
to kick it back to you first rox is that
score low is that too high is rotten
tomatoes wrong about jumanji it just
makes you question what happened
how did we possibly as a society get it
that wrong this time rotten tomatoes is
super wrong on this one because i don't
know anybody who thinks that this movie
isn't great and i'm sure somebody
listening right now is like well me i'm
the one person fine go have fun with
yourself because the rest of us love
this movie rotten tomatoes is really
wrong about this this should be in the i
i want to say in the 90s i mean this is
a really
really solid childhood movie that
definitely
y'all got this wrong roxy's given all
the way to the 90s how about you dorina
how do you see jumanji and the tomato
meter well i think it's actually better
than most adventure family movies
nowadays i think for the 90s
specifically i remember being a 13 year
old child in the theater enjoying the
crap out of this
being scared and thrilled not as scared
as steph's a bra obviously because she
thinks this is a horror movie but
it's not steph but i'm glad you think so
but it's so much fun it's so exciting
the cast is fantastic every single
ingredient to this movie should have it
at least in the 80s percent like i don't
know what happened 50 percent way too
low rotten tomatoes is wrong 52 percent
of the tomato meter it's rotten
according to that what does steph sabras
say about rotten tomatoes are they wrong
about i guess one of your childhood
horror movies
yeah i love raw and tomatoes but this
score disgusts me uh not to pull the
legend or the dead legend card but out
of respect for robin williams and the
joy he spreads specifically in this
movie but everything he does or did
why would this be this low like this is
this makes me sad because there's gonna
be kids who look up this movie saying
like old classics i should watch and
then they're gonna go on rotten tomatoes
and then they're gonna be like should i
watch it and it's like of course you
should watch it because like dorino is
saying this is one of the greatest
horror children films of all time and
it's like a ride from start to finish
a great ride scary it's so funny because
recently we were talking about the 1982
movie annie with our good friend alicia
malone and it's sort of like similar
where you have like a lot of darkness in
a children's movie you get some of that
in jumanji and well the the two recent
jumanji films with kevin hart and and
the rock and and all of them those are
like fresh on the tomato meter and on
the audience score so you know our hope
here i guess because i think rotten
tomatoes is wrong too i think this
should at least be a fresh movie if you
want to keep in the 60s fine but i think
it deserves to be fresh if for nothing
else because of what steph said out of
respect for the late great robin
williams if we have time i'll tell you
my robin williams story if not we'll
kick it to another day because we have a
lot more robin williams movies to
discuss on rotten tomatoes is wrong but
right now we turn it over to our good
friend tim ryan he's our expert review
curation manager here at rotten tomatoes
and he's going to tell us what the
critics were saying
wrongly so according to the world girls
at the time of jumanji's release tim
take us back to 1995
[Music]
occasionally people will tell me that
they're bummed out that one of their
favorite movies from their childhood is
a low score on rotten tomatoes and my
take on that is critics usually watch a
movie once before reviewing it and they
generally have no idea whether it'll be
embraced or forgotten in the future
my other take is you should never have
any shame if you love a movie or if you
have a happy memory of watching a movie
as a kid
those formative experiences help you
fall in love with movies in the first
place for a decent number of people of a
certain age jumanji was a formative
cinematic experience
as andre meadows of black nerd comedy
said in a retrospective review it was
totally one of those 90s movies
specifically made for 90s kids but at
the time of its release by and large the
critical opinion on jumanji was that it
took the bare bones of chris van
allsburg's wonderful book and turned it
into a special effects extravaganza and
that while those effects were admittedly
pretty impressive too often they pushed
the human characters off to the side
jumanji is rotten at 52 with 46 reviews
and it has a 62 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a rotten
review rita kemply of the washington
post wrote the technology both
overwhelms the human cast and stalls the
narrative drive even williams manic
energy finally flags however in a fresh
review ron yamagi of vancouver's georgia
strait wrote as he did with honey i
shrunk the kids director joe johnston
successfully juggles frenetic special
effects action with gentle character
moments the rotten tomatoes critics
consensus reads a feast for the eyes
with a somewhat malnourished plot
jumanji is an underachieving adventure
that still offers a decent amount of fun
for the whole family so that's jumanji
let's get back to mark the only way
you'll be able to escape the wild chaos
of this podcast is if you yell jumanji
at the end back to you folks
i don't even know if that one's gonna
get me out alive here tim and i guess
right now i can just shoehorn in our
synopsis about jumanji if you don't know
jumanji you discover a board game it's
not a video game like in the updated
versions it's a board game that these
kids discover in an attic somewhere and
they play it and wouldn't you know it
it's more than a game you play it's an
immersive experience where it's
dangerous and you can be trapped in
there for years such as the case with
robin williams character who's been in
there for 26 years he went missing as a
child his parents eventually just i mean
we don't know where he is he's gone and
then his parents passed away and then
he's back and we're trying to rectify a
lot of things but we also need bonnie
hunt's character sarah to help us solve
this mystery get robin free and get
everybody out alive of this really
really scary board game so with that
setting the table let's get to movie
talk for jumanji
[Music]
dorina nothing gives me greater pride
than to realize that you and i are two
of the more attractive folks that did
see this film in a theater when we were
kids so when you first saw this was this
like a movie that you had like circled
and you're like i want to go see that's
the one i want to go see did you just
walk into the theater because it was
movie day what was your relationship
with jumanji as you walked into that
theater for the first time
well mark i had already developed a
relationship with lady kirsten dunst uh
because she had just won an oscar
as a child for interview with a vampire
and obviously a huge fan of that movie
because i'm the goth whirl girl and i
was very excited to see this because i'm
also worshiped robin williams as a child
all right so any robin williams movie
that was out i was going to go see it
and my family my mom and my brother were
definitely huge movie lovers like myself
we sat there with our uh popcorn and the
hot dogs and sandwiches and mexican
snacks that we brought into the theater
obviously and we enjoyed the crap out of
this like i i was already hyped as a 13
year old girl and this to to quote the
wrong critic that uh tim read this movie
did not under achieve it impressed us so
much as a family because it looked
amazing for the time like the effects
were
totally groundbreaking it had a team of
people like ken ralston from death
becomes her uh tom woodruff jr aliens
like uh alec gillis who's uh famous for
animatronics from tremors like i was
like
this was like the arena movie i was so
excited it had horror elements uh it had
a bunch of cool effects uh cg mixed with
actual practical effects which is my jam
and i tend to miss a lot in these movies
and of course it had david allen rear
because you know he's like the funniest
guy i love that guy love me some david
allen career and i was a big fan of in
living color um roxy
jumanji when did you first stumble upon
jumanji and what was your gateway into
it was it the kids playing a game was it
you loved robin williams how did you get
in there i remember watching this on vhs
for the first time we had a room in the
house that just had a
very boxy tv in it and a mattress on the
floor and my brother and i used to sit
on the mattress and i remember we
watched this movie and a movie that
certainly did not hold up as well the
indian in the cupboard
we would watch those two movies back to
back one of those i stand by the other i
do not and he showed this movie to me
for the first time i believe he saw it
in theaters and then when it came out on
vhs he convinced the fam to purchase it
and we loved this one it was one of the
only ones that both him and i agreed on
we were only two years apart but when
you're kids that is a world of
difference and this was one of the only
i'm going to say there were five movies
that we could both be like all right
that's what we're doing tonight we must
have watched jumanji like 20 times are
you saying that it's not a finished room
if it just has a tv and a mattress in
there if that's the case i got some
redecorating to do
i don't know i asked my parents about
this a while ago why did we have a room
with just a mattress on the ground there
was no sheet on the mattress it was just
a mattress on the ground and they were
like it was very versatile we did a lot
of things with that room so i i don't
know just for you interior designers out
there something to think about
you can do a lot with a mattress and a
tv you can do a whole lot uh steph you
were introduced to jumanji was it a
family member twisting your arm like
roxy how did you first come upon this
game slash movie i don't remember the
moment of inception perfectly but i do
know similar to roxy there was two
movies that
me my brother and my sister would watch
and we loved so much and it wasn't robin
williams who we loved as like that took
longer in my life to realize what a
legend he was it was jonathan hyde
because in richie rich he's cadbury and
a
legendary character
and in jumanji's obviously the dad and
the
van hi the crazy guy who comes out of
the portal
but i
i so those two movies were just like
such great rides for me and i was so i
loved them both but jumanji was
genuinely scary and then upon re-watch
it was still scary the way that at no
point when i'm watching this film do i
think everyone's gonna make it out alive
and i think that's a huge indicator of
it being a horror film and the
characters make dumb mistakes like
horror like a horror movie but you're
there for it and you actually there's
moments of conversation like the
dialogue is really good still sometimes
when you re-watch 90s movies you're like
uh it's a little awkward but this one
i'm like i love this movie just the same
as i did when i was a kid and somehow
i'm just as scared
i'm glad you brought that up because i
found myself really gravitating towards
the emotional aspect of this movie when
i was re-watching it earlier this week
and so my favorite scene in the movie
going into it i was like i remember the
stampede scene
when the rhino just like crushes a car
how awesome that looked on the big
screen but it was a very different
moment upon re-watching it that got me
as an adult but the connective tissue is
there between like in indiana jones and
the temple of doom from the 80s where
kids were in in peril and then you have
like maybe guillermo del toro who's a
great horror filmmaker who made
something like pan's labyrinth where
again you you fear for how are these
children going to handle all of these
events and then sandwiched in between
those two decades would be something
like jumanji and so if we get into the
movie itself which is directed by joe
johnson and i point that out because
he's done a lot of movies that people
just loved from their childhood honey i
shrunk the kids he did he directed the
rocketeer the pagemaster um and he did
captain america at the first avenger you
know so
the the guy clearly has a lot of games
steph what's the scene for you that you
say see that's why i not only i love
jumanji but why everybody should love
jumanji
but maybe it's a little too scary for
the little tykes i would say okay it's
kind of a two-parter it's when robin
williams character first goes into the
portal and then right when he comes out
the first person out of there is this
man with a gun
chasing him and it's like how do you
make it out of that and i just every
time i'm like okay he's gonna be
murdered right on site makes it back to
his house he's gonna die he doesn't die
spoiler alert but i really thought he
was gonna die like this guy's coming at
him then he goes to buy a gun because i
guess that's easy to do in this great
country
instantly like it knows it's a yeah i
don't know it's just scary this guy's
chasing this guy these kids with a gun i
was like whoa
yeah rocks it really sets the tone
because well jumanji you would think
that the movie would steer you towards
wanting to play this game at no point
watching this movie did i ever want to
touch a game like that i looked at it
like a ouija board where i'm like just
get it out of my sight get it out of my
house i do not want to deal with this
game but what was it about the movie
that locked you in what was the scene
that you and your brother on that
mattress with no sheet just kept
watching over and over again there were
two moments that really stood out for me
the one the first one is so small that i
even upon re-watching it i was waiting
for it because i was like please tell me
i didn't make this moment up this has to
be a real moment this this is so much
about my childhood i'm putting a lot of
weight on this and it's when robin
williams says to go get the axe and and
as a monkey he goes to get the boy goes
to get the axe and he
goes he grabs the axe to open up the
thing and he's got the axe in his hand
and he realizes it it's like when
somebody says put on your sunglasses and
you search for like an hour and they're
on top of your head
i i love that moment as a kid so much i
i don't even remember that oh but it's
such a keynote
it's great yeah like i just remember i
used to laugh so hard because that is
the kid humor in here that i was just
like that's what happens you went to the
axes in your hand and you were trying to
get the axe it's the funniest thing
[Music]
but then as an adult for me i think my
favorite moment is when robin williams
is stuck in the floor it's just the
coolest to look at and i think that like
all of us feel when you're watching that
that's where is a little bit of a horror
movie i won't give stuff the the
satisfaction of saying that this is a
horror movie but if there are horror
movie elements it's when like you can't
use your hands you can't move you are
stuck and i don't want to see what that
would look like if there was death by
floor i don't know is that like by a
million splinters i mean how do you
really what really happens that's that's
part two that's pretty terrifying to
think about the the many different ways
that you could die in jumanji and if
you're in jumanji dorina you want to go
out like a champ like you want to be
facing a rhinoceros head to head you
don't want to just be hey how'd you die
how did you get up into heaven oh i was
stuck in a floor for all eternity so
couldn't quite pull it out what's the is
it the floor scene for you is it uh is
it some of the relationships in the
movie what's the scene for for dorina
now well there's a couple the the the
really bizarre one that i still think is
so bizarre but i love it and i don't
think any of you notice this because
you're not mexican but my mexican family
notices in the theater was when van pelt
who's the hunter uh who also plays the
dad goes into a gun store and buys a gun
and the entire scene the mexican
national anthem is playing in the
background even though they're in the
u.s it is so random but obviously
everybody in the mexican theater was
like yeah
i was like
what can i do for you i'll regress to
these
you know they stopped making these in
1903.
and i shall need a replacement weapon
well there's a waiting period
and you'll have to fill out these
or i could fill these out
louise
so that was a fun one but but uh an
actual like i love all the action scenes
like unlike steph i love anything that's
gory and i love uh you know when people
are in the in the actual movie are
scared but there's a really sweet moment
uh thanks to the great robin williams uh
where he's kind of having a moment with
the little boy and he's a monkey and i
think he has his tail stuck in his pants
and he's like helping him like get it
out but uh but at first he's very cold
with him and then he says i'm sorry 26
years buried in the deepest darkest
jungle and i still became my father
right so that's a really cool uh human
moment that we had there thanks to uh
the great robin williams of uh where
you're in a crazy adventure movie that
actually has this like big heart element
to it so i love that i warned you about
this peter
no you wanted to play the game
what are you crying
you don't cry all right you keep your
chin up come on keep your chin up
crying never helped anybody do anything
okay
you have a problem
you face it like a man
[Music]
hey hey
i'm sorry
26 years buried in the deepest darkest
jungle and i still became my father
yeah that was art imitating life a
little bit because that poor kid bradley
pierce played played peter uh and he was
in the makeup chair for you know hours
getting getting all that makeup on and
and he was interviewed about it and he
said that robin williams would come into
the trailer and just sit next to him the
entire time because robin had just come
off of filming mrs doubtfire where he
was going through a lot of extensive
makeup and so he was like teaching
bradley like meditation techniques just
like how to you know stay still and calm
your mind and try to not get too
restless and it's like just a guy like
that who could just be chilling in his
trail or doing like i would be napping
if i was the star of that movie when
it's not my time to shine i'm taking i
don't care about kids i'm taking a nap
he is in there supporting him and
ironically you all know me there's very
few things that can get me like
emotionally uh to show him on the
outside but it's the end when we get to
reunite the the the reuniting of a
family i was like oh my god why is this
making me feel things and i weld up a
little bit it's because we we just we
saw the thing and it would him and his
father particularly they were just like
ships passing in the night for like the
last 26 years ever since they discovered
the board game and so just to see it
have that sort of ending i was like it
just it made me feel so good and the
fact that we no longer have robin in our
lives as a current person it just it it
warmed my heart it made me miss him but
i was just i was feeling a lot of feels
and this is from the same guy who will
ball watching night of the museum three
at the end
because because robin williams plays
teddy roosevelt and the movie was
released after robin had passed away and
there's a scene at the end where he's
just he's talking to ben stiller's you
know manager character and it's almost
like he's saying goodbye to him but he's
also saying goodbye to us and so robin
williams has one of those i don't know
how he does it but he's able to tug on
my heartstrings like
nobody else um and and i think part of
that stuff is to your point where the
tone of this film is scary and there is
a lot of horrifying elements especially
for kids in here
do you think that that sort of
helps the movie in a way like stick with
you long after you've you've stopped
watching it for the first time long
after you've left the theater you keep
thinking about it because we felt like
we were in real serious danger
yeah definitely a hundred percent more
than a lot of
movies that i watched when i was a kid
this one really stuck with me because it
did it scared me just enough where i
still had fun watching it but you know
that scene where alan parish is talking
to the little kid he just got out and
he's like disheveled unshaved like
wearing palm tree hat
uh whatever that look was and he's like
you've only you haven't even seen the
things i've seen only in your nightmares
you think monkeys mosquitoes and lions
are bad that's just the beginning
i've seen things you've only seen in
your nightmares
things you can't even imagine
things you can't even see
there are things that hunt you in the
night
when something screams
then you hear them eating
afraid
you don't even know what afraid is
it's like oh my god it's getting real
right now are we gonna give this man
some support so yes yes those are the
moments where that's like oscar-worthy
robin williams coming through in a
children's movie but just elevating it
where if someone else said that line
like no shade to some of the new
adventure type movies we've seen um the
ones that resemble games or rides i
always know it's a ride or a game that's
really really made for children but
jumanji feels like it hit the sweet spot
of both like adult and kid fun and scary
yeah darina it's an essential part of a
lot of people's childhood and i think
that one of the reasons is because it's
lasted with us so long because it had
such a visceral impact the first time we
saw it when maybe we weren't like you
know adult even you and i watching that
in the theater it's like oh my god this
is like this is scary but it feels real
and i'm glad everything worked out okay
but there's a lot of scary crap like the
the the monkeys themselves like getting
stuck the bats in that movie the monsoon
there's a lot of scary
i mean scary i guess to a kid and to
steph but uh but for the 90s for sure i
mean it's it's similar to the feeling
that we all got watching jurassic park
for the first time in the theater right
where you're you're stressed out but
you're having fun at the same time kind
of like living life and experiencing it
uh but um i i do have to say like it
there's so many um
a stressful part specifically but also
funny in those stressful moments like
obviously the monkey's riding the
motorcycle is one of my favorites
because it's so stupid but also the
stampede i mean there's that rhino at
the end that's just like struggling to
catch up to the stampede and i think
that's the most relatable rhino on
screen wheezy i believe um and and roxy
i was reading some some research that
the great mark hoffmeyer did for us
about this movie and apparently that was
just because the visual effects team
they couldn't get the rhino to move any
faster and make it feel as realistic as
it was and so it was just a slow moving
rhino but it sort of endeared the
rhinoceros to me more like if it was
just the most the most athletic
rhinoceros ever i don't think i would
have responded to him roxy no super
relatable that rhino is the most
relatable character in the whole film
i'm with you guys like
we've all been that rhino before and
that's okay it's okay to be the rhino
that's the point of the film i i think
that it actually is
a scarier movie as an adult though
because did you your guy's mind starts
to wander too right like you are sitting
there thinking what were those 20-plus
years like right how are you still here
are you okay like i feel like therapist
rocks kicks in and it's like
tell me what that was like for you robin
what was that like for you
and the actual like mental fear of being
stuck for that long as a kid i don't
remember being afraid of this i remember
thinking it was so fun i remember
thinking those spiders because they
don't look like real spiders they look
like they look like big creepy crawlers
i remember thinking that that would have
been like oh cool you take the axe you
chop the spider like video gamey but as
an adult it's a lot scarier not horror
but scarier also to add to roxy's point
what about bonnie's bunny hunts
character she has to deal with the you
know 26 years of nobody believing her
that she saw this kid get sucked into a
board game yeah
that is insane believe herself she
when you hear her on the phone with her
therapist and she's like talk me off a
ledge he's sitting right here i see him
and you just like that i i have memories
like that i'm sure you guys do too as a
kid where you're like did i make my
whole life up
did this actually happen and to
to think that you saw something that
everybody around you tells you you're
crazy that's horror are we mad at her a
little bit though that she didn't roll
that die again
yeah she just ran and never looked back
but as a child staff you would have run
too admit it it's giving evan hansen
vibes
here's the thing
i feel like i would have run initially
i'm not gonna say that oh yeah i would
have i would have been the hero in that
moment but you know i might have ran and
then as i got a little older i might
have like gotten a gym membership and i
might have like hired a trainer and been
like hey
like a year from today i'm rolling the
dice and i'm going back in there after
my friend like i am getting in [ __ ]
you're getting in shape for for the
draft cool i'm going in shape to go to
the the jungle in a board game to rescue
robin williams like that's a pretty
that's a that's a you could also like
hire special forces maybe to play the
game with you because then they could
come in so exactly
i think there's workarounds you might
have experimented within that that 26
years but i do give her props for she
clearly made her decision like i'm never
going back to i'm never gonna revisit
this and the kids were able to convince
her hey sarah we kind of need you like
right now
i mean kind of we totally tricked her
into it which she won't roll the dice
and robin williams was like oh boom
there there you did it that's you
rolling it who are we really mad at i
can't believe william
but the way she rolled the dice the
first time as a child i know we
shouldn't blame children for stupid
mistakes but she was like
i'm not playing games i haven't played
the games in 10 years and she just drops
today so i'm like you just played the
die you just played the die sarah and
now you left your friend
but we forgive her it was full circle
it's full circle they needed to grow
together exactly stuff see everybody
was at fault but they every single
character there was growth throughout
the movie and that's important and not
seen as much in family movies i think
and then you look at the the special
effects the visual effects aspect of
this movie because dorina as you pointed
out there's some geniuses behind the
scenes here and some of it did build
upon what we saw in jurassic park a
couple years earlier and the director
joe johnston i love bringing him up
because he's made some of our childhood
favorite movies and he also worked on
both of those ewoks made for tv movies
the caravan of courage and battle for
rendor even before that joe johnson is
credited with the design of some little
green muppet named yoda he was sort of
you know kind of had that iteration of
yoda as this little green thing that
doesn't look like a jedi but he can
still make your x-wing come out of the
swamp when you really need it um design
me he did joe johnston hero he is
i didn't know if she'd do it i didn't
want to prompt her but roxy is famous
for having a great yoda impression and
thank you thank you for that rocks that
that means yeah that wasn't for you that
was for joe johnston okay
that was for joe that's for you joe
it's developed from sounding like gollum
meets pee wee but now it's actually
getting better roxy i have to give you
props i think it's really spot on and
you guys are all gaslighting me the way
that we gaslet sarah and for 20
something years when she thought that
she watched somebody disappear that's
what's happening here yeah yeah you have
the force yeah
can you sit this this can you say kids
down now in front of this movie in front
of this jumanji and you think they'd
respond to it do the effects hold up in
that sense because for us we're always
going to remember i think the first time
we saw it and and it felt so believable
to us do you think that we can do that
with kids of today i think if the kids
smart
they'll like it
i don't know i have okay i've
unfortunately have to spend a lot of
time
with the youth because i'm the oldest
cousin out of like a crop of 40 little
kids
and
they're
no wonder you drink beer i love ya i
love them but they're very pretentious
you know like they know a lot they're
smart
and so i think that if they just let the
ride take them they would really enjoy
it because it does hold up in so many
ways but i could see them being like
that cgi doesn't even look real like mid
movie and then they just they take
themselves out of it but i think there's
a big group that would still love it
yeah and you have the the jumanji
the two more recent ones you have
jumanji um you know welcome to the
jungle in the next level and i enjoyed
both those movies fine i really did and
i thought that they approached those two
films the right way to not
tread over to not rhino stomp the
previous jumanji and and dwayne johnson
is on record as saying like he didn't
want it to be a remake he wanted to be a
continuation because he wanted to honor
the legacy of robin williams do we feel
like that those two movies achieved that
that they're actually nice companion
pieces to the original i'll start with
you dorina
i mean i i only saw the first one um i
think it's it's a fun movie it just to
me maybe because i'm more of mark's age
it doesn't hold up uh to the same heart
that the original jumanji had and that
could just be because we're missing
robin williams right like i love the
original cast so much i love bunny hunt
i miss her kirsten dunst like i think
it's it's just a slightly different
movie that was made for modern times and
um and i still also miss a lot of the
practical effects in the animatronics
yeah they made a great point in uh in in
sort of making this movie that they
wanted to take the practical effects as
far as they could so make the practical
effects sort of the groundwork and then
just put the vfx on top of it and it
seems like you know a lot of movies
today for a myriad different reasons
that i'm sure are noble and they want to
tell the story that they want to tell
but seems like sometimes they do just
rely on visual effects but we're getting
back to a world where you do see some
more practical stuff than you used to so
that gives me some hope for the future
of movies like this roxy do you
appreciate what the new jumanji films
are bringing that they honor the legacy
of the original they certainly make
money they are both like within shouting
distance of a billion dollars worldwide
i think that they're excellent i think
the entire jumanji franchise hits it out
of the park because that's what if
you're going to do
a reboot or a sequel whatever we want to
call it when it's that far after if
you're going to do that then you need to
be true to the the story you need to be
true to the to the heart of it but you
should also take your creative liberties
and i feel like tonally they are very
different the characters we got really
fun new characters do i love them as
much as i love the og
85 jumanji no of course not because
what year was it did i make up those 95
95 yeah i was like no that's not right i
was i was born when this came out 95
jumanji
she's here i swear do i love it as much
as i love the 95 jumanji no i would
never because that would be sacrilegious
you know that would be horrible to the
inner child in me but did i think that
they were really fun watches both the
first and the second which was actually
very similar to the first but i didn't
care because it's fun enough that i
would sit down and watch it again
they were they were all so
lovely like they were funny they were
laugh out loud funny and they have
charismatic actors in them as well
nobody is robin williams but if we're
gonna start to pick people who can
really bring your attention to the
screen then yeah the rock's a pretty
good one uh kevin hart's are pretty good
we've got some pretty good ones there
yeah jack black karen gillan it's a
great cast and and they're fun to watch
but steph you pointed out earlier that
even even when you first saw this
jumanji the og it wasn't like you
weren't aware of robin williams as like
the person that you would come to know
and love i'm assuming we all love robin
williams here so i just want to ask you
all what was your entry point into not
just knowing who he was but holding him
as a beloved figure in your world do you
want you want us to start crying is that
what you want mark
i mean
it'll work for me so i mean look look
when i i'm probably like you where um i
first saw him in work and mindy
right like uh in reruns right so i i saw
him uh and i just thought he was funny
and i kept saying
and and i loved him but the first movie
that like actually made me cry as a kid
with mrs doubtfire because my parents
got divorced when i was five so i saw
that as a young child and i it was so
impressionable for me like at the end
where she where he does the speech as
mrs doubtfire on the tv and she tells
you know it's it's not your fault it's
going to be okay i was just like as a
little darina i was oh it was a whole
thing so every that ever since then i've
loved that man and i've seen every
single one of his movies i love that
they didn't get back together at the end
of mrs doubtfire yeah i thought that was
a really important thing because it just
feels like chris columbus or the team
knew a lot of kids are going to be
watching this movie this is going to be
a big hit let's not build up false hope
for all those kids from divorced parents
let's not make them all think that all
dad has to do is dress up like a woman
and everything will be fine and they're
going to get back together um i actually
didn't come across his work and mindy
work first my first intro to robin
williams was good morning vietnam and i
just thought it was funny watching this
guy in the military just yelling and
saying whatever he wanted to do on the
radio and then i went to a monday night
football game where we lost to the
cowboys and i was in like fifth grade
and
it was so late by the time we got back
my mom let me sleep in from school the
next day that's how cool my parents were
and so i woke up at like noon and i'm
thinking oh sweet i got the whole day
off and she's like no you're you're
getting dressed and you're going to
school but first you can watch the rest
of mork and mindy and i'm like what the
hell's mork and mindy and then she's
like you've never heard it's young robin
williams and i watched it and i was just
like this guy there's nothing this guy
can't do steph your first time realizing
the genius that was sir williams i don't
want to say it was flubber but it might
have been flubber
i think that movie hit really hard for
me uh something about it maybe it's
because the like
same time as nickelodeon slime we just
loved that our generation loved that but
i missed out fire was another one that i
feel like always was playing on tv and i
never got sick of watching it
and i think the more i was kind of like
a slow burn for me but then the more i
fell in love with comedy and comedic
actors the more i started to realize how
rare he was because a lot of comedians
can't break out of just being funny and
it's hard to take them serious and i
think kevin hart is starting to do it
now the rock's not or dwayne johnson's
not a comedian but he does like a lot of
comedic movies and to me it's hard to
look at them as serious actors too
and i think they need like separate
entities to show each showcase each it's
not usually in one movie but robin
williams in one movie could be serious
and funny and the same character in a
way that not really anyone else could do
it so it was just like the more and more
i kept watching it him and then
realizing his voice was in aladdin i
didn't know that until like 10 years
after i watched aladdin he's just like
what can't this guy do
uh steph you might have to stay parked
there and we'll just do another episode
right after this because unfortunately
flubber 24 percent on
lucy make a note we're probably talking
about clubber at some point
no soul rocky i'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that aladdin was your intro was
your gateway to robin i
i think probably
but obviously being from boston i have
there's one there's one that is like my
most memorable and of course it's good
will hunting uh you know when when
darina said it's not your fault speaking
about mrs doubtfire of course that uh it
almost brings you to tears thinking
about it's not your fault on repeat to
will um and this was the first this is
true this i think i must have been the
movie came out in 97 i was
probably three years after that i was
about 10 years old i had an audition and
i what i auditioned with was his entire
you don't know about real loss because
that only occurs when you love something
more than you love yourself and i doubt
you ever dared to love anybody that much
speech yeah i said i was 10.
i was 10. and that was the that was the
monologue i decided to perform because
he meant everything to me like this was
is there a tape of this is that video
evidence i gotta find something i mean i
i
at one point i knew every single word to
the entire movie but robin williams
character in that movie is the
he is the like soft place to land he is
the even though he's got a little edge
to him he is the voice of reason he is
the person that you need in your life to
explain things to you and to to make you
more of a human and less of a
cold-hearted brat and i needed robin
williams in so many different areas of
my life and he always delivered i love
this man so much
forever and always so let's take this uh
let's take this opportunity to talk a
little bit about [ __ ] out of water but
i want to keep it in the world of
jumanji so
y'all's new podcast endeavor is is you
relating life experiences that you've
had and it can be some heavy stuff it
can be lifestyle choices it can be
travels it could be really anything that
you have experienced and left a mark on
you how would the world girls handle
having either alan robin williams's
character or sarah bonnie hunt's
character and all of the i imagine ptsd
that they have from this board game
experience it feels like [ __ ] out of
water would be the perfect podcast for
them to really talk about what happened
i mean look [ __ ] out of water is really
uh the whole point of the world grows is
that we give things a whirl right and so
we give fun things the world like going
to disneyland and and creating uh bottle
rockets and celebrating holidays like
day of the dead but in this podcast we
talk about human experiences right and
um and and all kinds of things like
steph being mixed and me being
polyamorous and
roxy talking about grief and her mom
dying and so this is really where we
talk about our trauma and our you know
ptsd from all from from all of life's uh
amazing joyful as well as bitter
experiences all of the joy and the pain
and the suffering so i think that i
would love it if somehow in some other
dimension we could interview uh the
entire cast of jumanji and make them
feel a little bit better about the
things they're going through and also
kind of like jumanji how maybe steph
looks at it like a horror movie but
sometimes for me it's more of a comedy
this is the classic line that steph says
anytime we're thinking about the new
podcast episodes we're gonna do she's
like but we're gonna make it funny right
because we don't like we don't like to
just talk about the trauma without the
laughter so i feel like jumanji would be
very similar
yeah we'd be like remember you almost
died
like it'd be such a fun conversation
with them
but that's why you are the perfect three
folks that i know that i've ever met to
do an endeavor like this is because you
have heavy life experiences but you're
always able to inject humor into it and
that's how we cope with this stuff
that's how that's how i imagine uh you
know allen's parents um or it really any
that's how these kids when when they're
dealing with stuff because their kid
these kids lost their parents and you
know at least the beginning of the movie
we get to rectify some stuff towards the
course of the end but it's like there's
a lot of stuff going on here and so it's
just it's one of those things it's an
outlet that we all need and maybe that's
why this version of jumanji speaks to
all of us in our childhood and in our
adulthood is that there's something in
there for everyone and it feels real and
it feels emotional and it grabs you and
it doesn't let go
but the world girls do the world girls
and y'all can answer this individually
if you want to or as a collective i
don't care do the world girls you're
you're at home and you you're digging
around your attic and you find the board
game jumanji
do
you open it do you roll the dice 100
yes but these two i can't even get them
to do a ouija board with me right now
they're like true believers in
whatever's out there but i'm making them
play
i i have forced them to play jumanji
this is something that i'm gonna make
happen and plant spiders all over the
place and get a lion
i will tape my fists i'll take my hands
and i'll take 40s to them i'll be like
edward scissorhands with the 40s and
not participate you can't get me to roll
a die i'm not messing with the spirits i
like the spirits i come in peace i'm not
going to wake you up not rolling die
roxy that's all you
look but the here's the thing though
we're talking about you know both joy
and loss and jumanji and we haven't
talked about the great james horner by
the way who's also passed away and
composed the amazing score to this movie
but if somehow we got to reunite with
like james warner and robin williams and
all these people stuff would you play
jumanji if there was a guarantee i
wouldn't die or be um like mutilated by
some animal there's no guarantee ever in
life stuff here's what i'm thinking we
hold her down we tickle torture her we
put the dye in her mouth and then we
poke her stomach so she just spit it out
and roll i've already rolled yeah
honestly i think everyone listening you
just heard roxy's origin villain story
because that was evil
do it for the world girls do you
understand or not that's the assignment
i was in i was in on ticklish a little
bit but it's like i don't know she also
you got to remember she has two 40s tuck
tape to her hands and i'm a big fan of
beer grip steph so i don't want to mess
with that we can let her sit this one
out as as i said about ouija boards in
my special i don't believe in it but i
don't not believe in it get it away from
my house uh closing up shop here i i did
get a chance the first i i've actually
gotten to hang out with robin williams a
few times and every time it was just
like you wake up the next day and you're
like did that really happen first time i
ever met him saturday night before the
oscars at the comedy store he came in to
pop in on stage and in the original room
and i was an employee and he comes in
i'm the first one that he sees as he
comes through that front curtain you all
have been through that way in the
original room before and he comes in and
i'm just like oh hey robin i'm mark um i
just started working here and uh and he
said oh oh um
and he said yeah i think he said
something like and which department are
you and i said i i just answered phones
right now and so he pantomimed without
missing a beat holds the phone up to his
ear and he said oh i still have no idea
what i'm doing yet and uh and then he
gave me a big hug and then he went on
stage to a standing ovation and uh
killed for 20 minutes got off stage
another standing ovation and we got to
uh chew it up in the back for a little
bit and it's one of the uh
yeah
one of the great memories of a great man
that uh i will always
cherish so
that is going to do it for us here today
on just that episode where i knew my job
was going to be easy but you all made it
even more
simple for me to just set you up and we
just are off in a world of pure
imagination thanks to the world girls
who i love dearly uh let's talk a little
bit more and let all the kids know where
they can find the world girls empire in
general and then this new podcast
offshoot [ __ ] out of water
have at it i'm gonna let roxy do it
because she's the longest running host
here oh great
the world girls we we have a website so
we keep it nice and easy for you guys
the worldgirls.com if you want to find
our podcast laurelgirls.com podcast it's
everywhere that podcasts are apple
spotify and it's called [ __ ] out of
water i don't know if we made your job
super simple mark because we made you
say [ __ ] like 15 times this episode but
if you've ever felt like a fish out of
water [ __ ] out of water is for you plus
we are live every wednesday and sunday
nights on youtube.com the world girls we
give things a whirl so like darina said
anything from disneyland to day of the
dead uh to mukbang if you don't know
what that is go check out an episode in
which we try to eat a hundred pieces of
sushi and get really really sick never
have i shaken back and forth like that
in my life and uh you can also follow us
on social media at the world girls and
world girls [ __ ] if you're on instagram
a hundred pieces of sushi steph you must
have led the way on that one right
yes definitely mark thank you for
thinking that do not lie i did not lie
right now i held down the fort um
however away you want to interpret that
that's what i did i provided a lot of
support mark she she hid all the avocado
sushi by herself and ate that while
dorina and i had to eat all of the fish
sushi
it's on tape there's evidence she's an
avocado girl as the only japanese person
in this group i feel like it's my right
to do with the sushi what i wanted to do
but i would never throw you under the
bus it was just the avocado rolls were
by me
i mean
if i had to i'm not the world's biggest
sushi eater i will i will get it down if
if the challenge is brought and i would
probably lean towards the avocado sushi
because avocado hey kids that's the good
kind of fat so roxy streier dorina
ariano and steph sabra beer drinking now
steph sabra thank you all so much for uh
for for gracing us with your presence
and chatting jumanji best of luck i know
the podcast is going to be a huge hit as
is everything the world girls do and
please come back soon individually as a
team we just love having it here rotten
tomatoes is wrong gracias we love you
mark and ron tomatoes and lucy paducy
and brian
brian
the man
and the entire team here at rotten
tomatoes brian borrowing his friend
draco uh who's a little dog from
christian rival cava today so everybody
was in the house for this episode of
jumanji thanks for tuning in and we'll
catch you next time here at rotten
tomatoes is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you